black to play and find the don't say it
nobody say it
nobody say it black to play and find the
only winning move
this is your your your like mouth is
going to drop open i'll be right back
[Music]
oh i have the craziest example to show
you guys of a move
that
you know those engine moves where you're
like
what the hell is the point of that move
then you go through a line and on move
like eight of that line
this ridiculous pawn move is somehow
useful you know what i'm talking about
an engine proactive i have the greatest
example of that i gave to a group of
like 2300s i could show you guys if you
wanted honestly like stunning idea and i
could walk you through why this engine
move is made i would give people a
thousand attempts to find this move and
you wouldn't be able to
okay
so this is a completely obscure game
totally obscure
don't ask me how i found it i have my
methods
this is the world team championship
under 26 from 1993 paraguay against
bolivia
so i mean this is not a not a well-known
game at all so white has just played
queen
f1 e1 to f1
so let's take a moment before we do
anything
and just adjust yourself to this
position because we have to figure out
it's not going to be fun if you don't
know what's going on
right and i have to walk you through
very very methodically
exactly what's happening in this
position so what observations can we
make about this position okay well
before you look at any moves it's good
practice to start with material
start by making observations about the
way pieces are placed and then you'll go
into the moves so
black is down a rook
for two pawns black is down to work for
two pawns so it's very clear
that either we deliver checkmate or we
win back at least a minor piece or else
we will be lost
now
we can also see that there is a battle
going on around the king side like the
king side is where [ __ ] is happening
right
and it's where black has to make happen
or else black is going to
but white is going to consolidate and
white is probably going to win
so now we can start looking at moves and
the obvious first move the move that you
know
that
everybody and their brother would play
and black played this in the game as
queen h3 check
all right
now this is not as hard to calculate as
it may appear
if white plays king f2 then white gets
checkmated in one move queen g3
so white has to play the move king
q1
okay
now
in this position the queens are staring
at each other and a queen trade is
devastating for black unless black can
at least get a minor piece right
so
black has a couple of tempting moves
here but i will save you the trouble and
i will say
that the only serious way of continuing
the attack
and if you have any specific questions
you can ask
but queen e3 check is the best move
we need three check is the best move
yeah no if you play f3 here which i know
some of you are tempted by white's just
gonna take the queen
white's just gonna take the queen and uh
you can only take one piece at a time
right
so there's a nice line here
bishop e3 check you can say oh i have an
intermediate move
and then i win i can take the bishop
what does white do in this position
unfortunately this does not work out for
black if white takes the pawn i need to
then okay white is up in exchange but
it's a game unfortunately there's king
g2
and white takes the rook in h3 and
you're down a gazillion pieces
so
f3 queen takes h3 fails
um knight takes f3 guys blunders mate i
mean like bishop e3 check and then queen
takes h1 is made so it's actually quite
important that the queens are staring at
each other
so for that reason you need to move your
queen
and so you should move it to e3 check
first
if king g2 then you get mated
if queen f2
then it appears that black's attack has
reached a cul-de-sac but now it's time
for f3
now it's time for f3
now let's go through the lines
if
white plays queen takes e3 now we have
the same exact position as in the line
we just looked at with the exception
with the exception
that uh here the rook is there is no
queen on h3 i mean we've literally gone
the same position with no queen on h3 so
if white plays king g2 black does not
have a queen that he needs to take
so white plays king takes e2
but at this position we should realize
that now black has a bishop for the rook
as well as a pawn and you can take a
second pawn hey
a bishop in two pawns for the rook is
essentially extra material for black
black is doing totally fine here let
alone let alone the fact that white's
king is really weak and the rooks are
discombobulated this is fine right
hopefully everyone's following so far
but there is a problem in this position
white has another move white does not
need to take the queen immediately
can anybody name
what you what you think might be
another
calm very calm move for for white
so i'll give you a hint it's taking on
f3 but which piece should take on f3
calculate
yes very good the bishop
because if the knight takes then the
king is overloaded it's defending
both the rook and the queen so we take
the rook and white is busted white loses
the the queen right
so bishop takes f3 happens
but black plays knight takes f3 check
right
okay
now if knight takes f3 well then we
already know the drill we take the rook
on h1 and we win the game
but the problem is that white suddenly
doesn't have to take on f3 queen f3 is
illegal queen f3 is illegal king g2
now the line goes on the line goes on
you might look at this and say well wait
a second
black is good we take the queen with
check
king takes f2
and uh
we're in
fantastic shape we play
knight takes h2
and we have two pieces for a rook
but still the line goes on
here
white plays the move king g3
and wins the knight on h2 that knight is
trapped
and if you rewind for a second
in addition to playing queen takes f2
black can start with rook takes h2 check
rook takes h2 queen takes f2 and then
knight takes h2 and who can remind me
sorry who can remind me of white's move
in this position
what is white's move in this position
this is the important line this is the
line you should pay attention to
king g3 and the knight is trapped the
knight is trapped and in the resulting
position white is a bit better now
remember
we are not talking here about like a win
for white black is winning in the
initial position but with an only move
this is an incredible line so to recap
to recap
we have been calculating the following
line queen h3 check king g1
queen e3 check queen f2
f3 bishop f3 knight f3 check king g2 now
either either queen takes f2 check and
knight takes h2 or more pertinently rook
takes h2 check
something like this was played and white
lost very quickly white uh blundered
into mate
uh knight takes h2 and it looks like
black is home free but king g3 traps the
knight
now in order to solve the problem
we need to figure out under what
circumstances
under what circumstances and i know some
of you are good at plugging the position
to the engine
under what circumstances this final
position would be winning
under what circumstances what needs to
be the case
what button needs to be pressed for this
to be winning for black well
the knight has to be able to move back
to g4
and so we go all the way back to the
start
the only winning move and i will prove
this to you by turning on stockfish is
h5
and the entire point is that white has
no effective move white white's only
move here is to go something like rook
to d1
ever i know schuman said every other
move loses so let me give you a couple
examples
if white goes knight f3
then queen g4 and queen g3 is checkmate
if y tries to run with king f2 then we
go at it from the other side we go queen
d2 and this is winning
if white goes queen f2 then we give a
check
and we go f3 and we are winning
why are we winning here because after
bishop takes f3 knight takes f3 queen
after we have this check on e3 and we
win the game
so trust me on this i'll show this to
you with an engine but rook d1 is the
only move what do we do now we already
know what to do check
check
f3
bishop takes f3 knight takes f3 king g2
rook takes h2 the same exact line but
after king g3 there is knight g4 we
extricate the knight we have two pieces
for the rook and we have the past spawn
and we have another extra pawn this is
completely winning
this is chess
i think i actually did a pretty decent
job of walking you through this i feel
like
i mean i was able to explain the
uh the significance of the move h5 this
is unfindable over the board completely
unfindable
but this is beautiful and what's you
know what what the most beautiful thing
about this is it's that it's the only
winning move
what i love the most about this is that
it is the only winning move there are no
other moves that even come close to
doing anything good look
here's the proof
here is the proof
h5 is the only winning move at a high
depth i would never find h5 i don't
think magnus would find h5
with that and and the only way you can
find such a move
is to reverse engineer
the final position and also to realize
remember what's so hard about this is
that it's a slow move you might think
you're giving white an entire tempo like
am i really saying that there is nothing
white can do against that combination
well that's exactly what i'm saying but
to determine that is incredibly hard you
have to see this line
and by the way there's some ridiculous
lines in other positions too here rook
takes h2 rook takes h2 and f3 is winning
this is amazing and i have some other
examples of this if you want i could
show you other like i i did an entire
lecture in my last chess camp
about these types of moves and like
basically how to try to find them
and i think this is i think this is a
lot of fun so i can show you guys
another really really cool example
so as you can see this is quite a
well-known game kamskin anon played a
candidate's match in uh india in 1994.
that's how long kymski has been good
analog bishop has been good
so this is a martial attack very good
anonymous savant this is not the moment
yet guys the in this in this position of
ishii found or sorry kamsky found a
beautiful tactic this tactic is
beautiful but it's not
you know so beautiful that
it's something to write home about
so
he finds an interception and
interception tactic he notices that the
knight on hf3 is a type 2 undefended
piece the queen is aiming at it
and he says okay
if i can intercept the connection
between the queen and the knight and my
queen gets to f3 oh there will be hell
to pay and he finds the move rook 8 to
e3
now the reason knight e3 does the same
thing but doesn't work is because it
blunders the rook on e2
so 93 doesn't work you have to play
rookie we have to keep the connection
between the rooks
here's how this works
if white plays f takes e3 it's very easy
you play queen takes f3 check uh sorry
not check but but mate is unstoppable
one thing i want you guys to notice rook
a8
is totally innocuous just king f7
right there are no more checks
if if if if if bishop takes e3
then black plays queen takes f3 and
what's unstoppable here thank you lazy
for the two month two years
what's unstoppable here is the move
knight takes e3
i want this to make sense to everybody
otherwise the rest of it won't be fun
this is winning on the spot you're going
to play knight takes e3 and there's
going to be a gazillion mate threats
okay
so
in this position anand plays a move and
all of the people annotating this game
assumed that it was the only move he
plays rook a8 check
and after king f7 he finds a very
beautiful defensive idea it's wrong but
it's still beautiful he finds the move
knight g5 check
distracting the queen from h5 and if
queen takes h5 happens white takes the
rook on e2
and because of this pin white emerges up
in exchange rook takes e2 bishop takes
g5 and it's an end game white is winning
so this drives the king out of its shell
and leads to a bunch of complications
that we'll get to in a second
yeah kamsky plays king g6 and the game
continues we'll get to that in a moment
as it turns out rook a check is a losing
move
and there was an incredible sequence
an incredible move for white
that leads to a draw
what's so crazy about this move is that
it comes absolutely out of nowhere
out of nowhere and the defensive concept
behind it is absolutely stunning
i'll let you guys think about it for a
second
okay
so
i could give you a hint ooh knight g5 is
close but no
it's not knight
g5 it is 95. hans in the chat yeah this
will be actually interesting to han
since this is like
craig and and we haven't even reached we
haven't even reached the pinnacle of it
this is just the start 95.
now what is the purpose of this well if
rick takes d3 you get checkmated no not
like that you get checkmate in a a
but you might say well wait a second i
don't get it just bishop takes c5 this
doesn't change anything unless it turns
out it does
because now white plays bishop takes e3
and in fact black is an only move that
draws the game
it is now black who has to be careful
here's where the point is revealed
you might say okay well wait a minute
wait a minute we discussed this line
right we discussed this line we said
black is winning so how can 95 possibly
change anything
we just play queen f3 and we're winning
but here was the point of knight e5 now
white takes on e5
and if you play knight takes c3 what's
the difference between this position
and uh
this position
well the difference is only that the d
file is open and that's all white needs
queen d a check is winning for white
because this leads to a checkmating
attack
this leads to a checkmating attack
so in order to draw the game black has
to basically say i cannot allow d-take
c5 to happen on the board which means i
need to give this bishop up but you need
to give it up in a way that forces white
to respond and so the only drawing move
is bishop takes g3
h takes g3 queen f3
and now rook a check and rook a7 check
yields a draw and the cherry on top
is that if black tries to run away from
the checks
rook takes g7 check
king takes g7 bishop h6 check wins the
queen
and if this is not beautiful i don't
know what is so
a draw by repetition is forced white
cannot make any progress and neither can
black because knight takes e3 is the
threat this is a draw
rook takes g7 check by the way i think
it might even lose to king h8
black cannot take the rook
okay
so
what else do i have to say about this
position 95 is the only drawing move
instead rook a check
knight g5 check we go back to the game
continuation king g6 and now we get to
the second stunning position
bishop takes e3
knight takes e3
now
anand finds a really really cool move
he plays rook d1 to f1
rook d1 to f1
and in this position godakamsky takes
the knight on g5 the position gets
complicated and the game eventually ends
in a draw
okay
now what black is a winning move here
that is
probably equally as stunning as the 95
resource that white had
and here's how i would spell out this
position
now essentially essentially
uh we need to figure out what's wrong
with king takes g5 because king takes g5
creates a gazillion threats it creates
the threat of queen f3
but to the rescue comes the move rook a8
to e8
all of a sudden the knight on e3 is
attacked just in time
and if you play queen f3 then rook takes
c3 holds everything together if you take
the rook on e8 then white takes the rook
on e2 and white wins
so kamsky was forced to play f4 queen e4
and then things get wild like things get
crazy here in the game it's in a draw
so what you need to do
is figure out a way to get rid of this
knight
but without disrupting the coordination
of all of your pieces
so the question therefore becomes what
is the only piece that is currently
unemployed what is the only piece that
isn't doing anything that could be doing
something the king the queen the knight
the rook are all
doing something they're all holding
together
this
attacking mechanism the only piece
that's not doing it is the bishop and
bishop f4 is the only winning move
bishop f4
and here's the crazy part
if gf4 you get checkmated
queen g4 queen g2
there's nothing white can do
if white goes knight e6
then you calmly drop the bishop back to
h6 thank you anonymous for the sub the
whole point is that f4 is now protected
the next move is queen f3 and you win
the game
um
yeah totally obvious
if hg you take the bishop and you win
anonymous gifting to sausalito
there is nothing that can be done at all
to bishop f4
so the whole point is that you need to
do this without allowing this rookie 8
resource if white plays rookie 8 here
then obviously you play bishop takes g5
and
white cannot take on e3 because if
bishop takes c3
so
you recruit the only piece that's not
doing something
and this is why by the way h6 does not
work white still has rookie a and again
the knight on e3 hangs
so bishop f what do you mean this game
antique like what do you mean by
antiquated
yeah bishop f4 is the only winning move
so these two moments i think
are incredible the annotators in this
game didn't find it
maybe it was discovered elsewhere i
don't know i haven't read every book
where this game was annotated
but uh just 95 might be even more
beautiful because 95 is such a crazy
move you just
you know to not take the rook here to
not give a check on a8
is crazy and look at this line take
stakes and then bishop g3
and then a perpetual because you can't
go to g6
and then of course you have this crazy
moment
where the only winning move is bishop c7
to f4 but the logic is perfectly clear
like you should now understand exactly
why this move is made this move is made
because
you need to get rid of the knight why do
you need to get rid of the knight in
order to play queen f3 why do you need
to play queen f3 in order to checkmate
on g2
so we do the recursion all the way back
so why can't we get rid of the knight
well it's because after rookie 8 our
pieces are overloaded and the knight is
going to be captured so we have to do it
in a way that also preserves the knight
on e3 and you play bishop f4
and if you get coached by me then you
can find moves like bishop f4 and you
can find move like bishop before you
become as good as hans pretty quickly
if you've become as good as hans you get
invites top tournaments and then you
conquer the world
[Music]
thanks hans for participating by the way
i really appreciate it i hope you
enjoyed this
[Music]
you